[Musique]
à partir de demain sur la ligne 29 gare
Saint-Lazare porte de monte en poivre la
RATP mettra en service 20 autobus d'un
type nouveau mais en avant-première
voici l'un d'entre eux et à son bord
monsieur Guerber ingénieur en chef
adjoint de la RATP devant les
difficultés croissantes de la
circulation parisienne la Régie a décidé
de mettre en service sur un certain
nombre de cellules les autobus de
dimension plus réduites les lignes
choisies sont des lignes à itinéraires
particulièrement difficile qui emprunte
soit des voies de grande largeur mais où
la densité de circulation est
particulièrement forte soit des voies
étroites ou le stationnement irrégulier
nous empêche parfois de passer soit des
lignes qui ont des virages difficiles à
réaliser d'une rue étroite dans une
autre rue étroite virage quelquefois
empêché complètement par le
stationnement irrégulier mais quelles
sont les caractéristiques de cette
autobus et bien les caractéristiques de
cet autobus les suivantes une largeur de
2 mètres 25 et une longueur de 9 mètres
alors que l'autobus normal a une largeur
de 2 mètres 50 et une longueur de 11
mètres d'autre part la capacité de ces
voitures et de 45 places dont 28 à 6
alors que l'autobus normal à une
capacité de 70 places dont 40 à 6 la
diminution de capacité a été largeur
plutôt a été obtenu en supprimant un
siège sur un des côtés du couloir mais
la Régie a déjà utilisé des autobus et
la dimension réduite c'est exact vous
faites allusion aux autobus bleu qui ont
été mis en service il y a quelques
années mais ces autobus ont une capacité
trop réduite 32 places ils ont d'autre
part une largeur qui atteint tout de
même 2 mètres 45 et enfin ils ne sont
pas conçus pour le service à un agent il
ne permettent la montée des voyageurs
que par une seule ville alors que
l'autobus à gabarit réduit permet la
montée de deux fils simultanées de
voyageurs celle de droite réservée aux
voyageurs porteurs de tickets et de
gauche on voyageur utilisant des cartes
hebdomadaires monsieur vous avez conduit
des anciens autobus quelle différence
pour vous il y a 100% de différence avec
les anciens d'autobus lorsqu'on a une
visibilité parfaite et puis une conduite
qui est beaucoup plus souple et plus
rapide à mon point de vue en effet
service plus rapide pour les usagers de
cette ligne des servi par un nombre plus
important d'autobus 20 au lieu de 14
pour compenser la capacité moindre de
chacun d'eux et dans les semaines qui
viennent cette expérience sera étendue
aux lignes 58 République Vanves 69 place
Gambetta Champ-de-Mars et 89 gare
d'Austerlitz Vanves
[Musique]